Blakely has the most difficult job in Cincinnati Zoo.
He has to play with babies all the time.
He's never shown any aggression or snapped.
If he gets upset, kinda like any mom would, he just leaves the room.
You are so cute!
My name is Dawn Strasser and we're at the Cincinnati Zoo and Botanical Gardens.
Blakely is a five-year-old Australian Shepherd, we got him from a rescue.
And I use him in the nursery as a nanny or companion dog.
This is about you and you're taking a nap!
Blakely's here for the main purpose of teaching the babies...
...the correct animal cues as they grow up.
So, when they are introduced back to their own kind,...
...they know what appropriate behavior is.
He teaches them how to play, how to interact.
I can tell them, "No, don't bite me," but I'm not an animal...
...and I don't give the same cues that he can.
So, we make a great team.